hello and welcome to see they're playing
tiger mama elbow hugger amor el
marmalades so what is he going to play
he sometimes plays quite him yeah I know
it's a mixture of normal openings and
sometimes it just plays a downward fishy
stuff let's see what it is this time
it's a our gang gals yeah popular
popular line and multiverse Bishop c5
first and then maybe we should be
satellite and cable TV I just play
normal developing developing moves and
see what happens ok probably wants to
know that's not blunder you for not sure
maybe it didn't hang wit and still
probably is going with some c6 yeah that
looks solid for black
mmm yes regroup to some kind of looks a
lot like a Philly doors defense in a
pretty decent form not sure about my
bishop a tua knight on c3 how well they
are positioned okay interesting he takes
that room I didn't expect that night f5
yep so my death I if I okay I can do
this just wonder if there's something
would have seven would probably not and
then 23 days possibly 95 but still looks
like the right move
not sure if i have the thread here late
age six didn't threaten much i just get
everything into the game all pieces yeah
that doesn't look very good but how do i
punish it just back not sure where I
actually
and uncie for ya look like be three
looks downright strange to take it hmm
not sure if I want to take it again
getting out of any possible check there
first and see later and show how to
prove how to improve okay so he is doing
something just take it can also take c4
and play e5 maybe this is good I don't I
don't really know this is tough to
decide here
I know maybe after c5 is good with this
bishops there
not so happy with this but I didn't see
another move and now they were different
to move let's say didn't see one
not not easy here right and we have to
activate stuff here we can just take em
I'm not sure why it take take and the
tacit he still has some passive pieces
it's not all great what he has maybe
night age six or something no
ok
pairing 94-95 Quincy for isn't and maybe
bishop CA does the thing I wants to go
Bishop c8 after that home I don't have a
good square then it's a bit of shame hmm
I can take and shake or something should
have thought for just a second day check
your tick stuff really in your tech
giving him such an ez pawn down okay
maybe it's not so terrible
and how to take it is that so clear
dunno maybe it is but one at least looks
somewhat dangerous hi morning
no training queens is probably nonsense
ok let's do stuff you cannot move I
cannot do much with the Queen here
alright we just do three now you can
take edge for now that you Lassie no he
doesn't see it yeah unfortunately I have
nothing came why yeah not a good game
not a good game champ I don't know we're
out here this is certainly quite nice
but I couldn't really make anything
happen it looks just like a great
position for white but it's not it's not
clear cut I couldn't really figure
something out here ticks ticks and now
this I Bishop on b7 that's just an
immensely strong piece I mean it's
pieces there look strange but the bishop
on b7 compensates for everything or even
overcompensates yeah here ok Bishop g1
might be better here the position looks
look strange but this is just a very
stupid move narrative threatens Bishop
by three it's just it's just a bad
position and this Bishop is too strong I
probably have to play something
something different here
sure I don't know it's sometimes tricky
had those efore positions it's really
not why my usual kind of kind of game
and it makes it difficult sometimes this
is certainly okay for white I mean this
can never be worse but I couldn't really
figure something out maybe King h1 is
it's too lazy
Jeff stuffed the same I mean the engine
gives Y just a slight advantage share of
the 94 it wants to take and then play
Queen tf2 very mysterious is that the
engine wants to go see 5c 5 why not t5
is that wrong and then we should be
three okay sorry to be six ok I
understand this makes d5 and need
somewhat unattractive ok there is very
very difficult I mean here I'm
definitely worse and I just hate hate
this kind of position this is just a
fantastic piece and white has no clear
plan you don't get a passed pawn or
anything with this with this e 5 p.m.
somehow those pieces that keep a white
pawns at babe yeah ok tough game thanks
for watching